[Music]
a bus driver
was sacked for being too short sacked
after 34 years on the job after 34 years
exactly yeah it got tackled attack was
like
why did it take why did it take that
long to realize how short he was and if
he's done the job she she sorry if she's
on the job for 34 years then why would
they fire her now well great question
michael yes yes tell me what you want
straight tell me can we guess first yes
please she spit on a kid
she didn't want to sleep with her boss
she didn't want to sleep with her boss
okay
what's yours do you want to sleep with
her
i don't know dang what kind of what did
she do she was racist okay racist joe
she farted she farted okay mike maybe
she got like leg surgery and she got
shorter she got shorter damn what i
don't know imagine getting less surgery
now this is what she looks like see my
three no no here's the camera
she's like now i feel bad for saying
that you know what's ironic about you
feeling bad for saying that you murder
what it's still 20 21 so i can call you
that
she got sacked because she's too short
oh she can't see above the [ __ ] thing
so a woman who's been working as a bus
driver for 34 years says she's been
fired from her job because she's too
short tracy scholes has worked at the
queens road depot in greater manchester
for more than three decades but was
given her notice last month
union unite claims she was let go
because bus firm go northwest has
repositioned the wing mirrors on the
buses meaning five foot tall tracy is
now too short to use them at the same
time as the pedals that's sucked but
she's been doing it for 30 years it was
they got new buses they yeah they
repositioned the window
or something like she can yeah
extend the pedals out yeah for her
specifically i mean
you know they they don't have their own
bus like they have to use yeah
like whatever bus of the day where they
really didn't care like about that's
what it sounds like it sounds like they
didn't really try to help probably more
of the situation where it's like
something bigger happens and and
collateral damage slash compromises are
necessary for the evolution of something
that's broader than a single individual
she can't get a really long shoe yeah
like shape-ups yeah she ain't no sketch
or shape ups she can't wear a [ __ ]
[ __ ] stripper stripper platforms
she there's you know those clear hooker
heels yeah they're like this big hooker
heels that's the solution they're just
like hey tracy get some hooker heels i
don't know she'll be should be five
three when she pulls up or five five
five six five seven with brown eyes
red bottoms specifically oh that'll be
retired so last month the bus driver
last month unite the union claims bosses
ruled that tracy no longer had the
capability to safely drive their buses
and offered her an alternative role at
the company that's cool that's cool
what's the alternative but for less
hours than picks
you can't do that right you got to give
her a better option or [ __ ] say peace
[ __ ] yeah she needs her pension her
retirement on that [ __ ] 34 years she put
in work for the company
she can't be a manager or something it's
her fault though she was born with a
[ __ ]
birth defect
a birthday oh
should have been hanging upside down
every day she should have been jumping
you know yeah
that's my tummy might have actually like
compressed a lot my mom says my mom says
you jump every day you get taller maybe
if you jump and then you've got the ball
in the bar and you hang and then you
drop and you do she shouldn't [ __ ]
play basketball dude
cause michael jordan grew even more in
college you sure it's not because uh
all right so
anthony tracy declined the offer and was
given 12 weeks notice she has now
launched an appeal over the decision
tracy i want to endanger the [ __ ]
kid's life
but yeah what if it was really bad we
can't win dude
like it was just want to keep her down i
get it because it's all like yeah but
then at the same
time you know if you can't do the job
safely get the [ __ ] out of there
or she could get those you know those
cycling helmets
that have your own rear view mirror
and that way you don't need to use the
bus rear view mary just use your only
review
like she wants she won't be able to see
the [ __ ] you just drive like this and
you can just look to the side she's
hanging out the way even worse
oh my god do you do you think it's
easier to move the mirrors lower or to
move the pedals up higher
in one bus because joe said they they
they switch buses all the time oh i mean
it's got to be all the buttons so like
she's not a whole bunch it's easier for
her to get hooker heels yes because
she's the the changing variable yeah
whereas the buses are constants or maybe
they can make the seats you know if they
had adjustable seats i feel that that
could be like this is such a step back
for the bus design you know like it's
just yeah because five feet
is pretty short but it's not that short
where you can't how tall are you i'm 5
1. yeah it's short as [ __ ]
but i mean they could drive regular cars
it's not like they're hospital weight i
mean height plus bullet can't drive by
that fool's like two feet yeah we are
talking about like the [ __ ] elephants
of the freeway though right we're
talking about like a commercial what
city is this in this is in greater
manchester but she's been doing it for
30 something that's the thing they don't
got traffic like l.a bro she's been
doing it proficiently for 30 years she's
good she's good but the bus has changed
though
because i always think like well if it
wasn't putting other people in danger
then why [ __ ] not but then if it's
one of those things where she's like i
just want to keep my job but then the
job consists of doing things like really
really really safely
because you have so many people in the
car with you yeah it's like i don't know
like what if a pilot right like is like
he's like not as
good with his eyesight and then they're
like sorry we got new [ __ ]
windows or whatever right yeah because
you can't work here anymore
or whatever and then he's like ah but
but i still want my job and i was like
yeah but you might crash and [ __ ]
that's also true it sucks but i think
it's time for her to move on
to better things yeah serve her she
could do like a mini bus driver
like a [ __ ] the short bus yeah short bus
driver like that let me go ahead and
make the story a little bit more
dramatic she's 57 years old says this is
heartbreaking i'm a widow of three
children a house and a mortgage and it's
nearly christmas all right give her a
job give her a job give her a [ __ ]
job
drive limousines or some [ __ ]
she has experience we're black you know
what you mean she's oh that [ __ ] uber
hire her please
party bus she could do a party or she
could drive the bank bus oh she can
drive the bang bus because the it's
technically not a bus oh
yeah uber oh yeah oh man
i bet they pay well
yeah no that was their last season
they're uh
she works for a different city that it
has the old buses
i'm sure she'll find a good job oh it
constantly moves around until the buses
continue to upgrade
okay double decker ones yeah i mean like
maybe it's like yeah the other bigger
buses
with more buses
oh that's that's kind of sad i moved to
like an asian country where her money
like you know it means more and she
drives smaller vehicles that's true
and then yeah the buses are smaller in
asia aren't they i'm making that up i
think they're the same they are the
chairs are just smaller or realistically
we're in 2021 somebody needs to start
like a random gofundme for her and then
she all of a sudden gets like a million
dollars for no [ __ ] reason and she's
good i saw a girl put up a a gofundme
for her trip to thailand and she got
paid some decent money what i mean
you know what i think we should go fund
her career change in being a train
conductor
she looks like she would be a really
cute one yeah except the [ __ ] mirrors
up here in the pedal down here oh no
trains are even bigger what are we
talking about right standing right but
yeah yeah it's on track she's gonna
shovel coal though
that's tough yeah she's like my dude
[Music]
right man what are we going to do
yeah what about the [ __ ] hyperloop yo
put it on the hyperloop put her in the
height
except it's ran by i don't know a robot
yeah
she should just be the passenger
that's her job be a passenger
yeah manage yo yeah you can do that all
right i like that idea let's do that i
think we gotta we got a good amount
we'll propose to
when we meet with her presentation we
gotta ask her what she wants to do
because she's like all i wanna do is
bust in what's like
all right well check this out we gotta
find a city that still has the old buses
yeah she could do like school bus yeah
you know because she can't be
unreasonable she can't be like nah
that's my passion man i [ __ ] spent 30
years and i'm like look dude like
technology changes mirrors get replaced
and [ __ ] you know let me add some more
drama she says
i love my job i don't want to lose it i
have regular customers and a regular
route
that's the thing imagine imagine putting
34 regulars not just into your job but
into almost like your community building
your life because every day it's like oh
what's up girl yeah this is a regular i
thought it was a school bus was a
regular no this is a regular uh an
actual bus city bus that runs the route
yeah that sucks
what she needs to do is get a brazilian
butt lift oh [ __ ] then she could sit
like three inches higher as you can see
the mirrors now higher means her feet
are farther from the pedal
plus the hooker heels it'll be a match
it'll be a perfect match
yeah hooker heels and butt lift she just
do that thing with she like carrying a
cane all day and just like push the [ __ ]
off oh yeah push the pedal like this yep
put a little shoe at the edge of the
cage solution
solution got it now she could not only
bust but on the she could have a side
hustle of a only fans with the brazilian
butt lifts and the hooker he read my
mind joe i was about to say that you
said it
and now she could make a triple income
so did you solve your problem we should
be a consulting agent
or or realistically that the [ __ ]
company just needs to come to you know
for a 34-year dedicated like very very
wholesome woman who's worked really
really long don't throw a settlement
that's like nobody gets to argue on
either side that's what settlement is
right it's like a number where it's like
oh damn is a lot of money for this
unique situation but we're comfortable
with it and i've heard like i'm
uncomfortable losing losing this job but
that's that's a good amount of money for
the situation it's nobody's fault yeah
and it's not her fault at all too it
sucks it's unfortunate
you